well I haven't kept track of this
officially admittedly but I'm guessing
that of all the states in the Country
California has been featured in The
Daily cancellation of this show the most
this is perhaps these days the only good
thing about California yes the entire
state is a degenerate Cesspool covered
in sewage but at least it provides
plenty of content for the last segment
of my show and today the good news is
that they've done something so stupid
that it graduates to the first segment
now as the Daily Mail reports this week
in a little over a month from now a new
law will go into effect in California
now is this a law that addresses the
homeless problem in the state is it a
law meant to clean up the streets Tamp
down on the rampid crime get rid of the
sewage make Community safe and livable
again well no of course not I me why
would California's lawmakers care about
doing any of that now this is a law to
address a far more pressing concern for
them and that is gender neutral toy
sections now we know that leftists they
see the toy industry like they see
everything else and ideological iCal
Battleground another politicized Arena
to defeat traditional concepts of gender
and Usher in a new ambiguous dystopia
where kids can live as amorphous
genderless Blobs of nondescript matter
and so now they have a law to that
effect the Daily Mail has more Reading
California retailers that refuse to have
a gender neutral section for children
will be fined up to $500 under Gavin
Newsome's new bill the ultra woke
Governor signed legislation in 2021 that
would require some retail stores in the
Golden State to have a gender neutral
section for children retailers would
have to do this regardless of whether
they've been traditionally marketed for
either girls or for boys the bill said
the legislation assembly bill number uh
10584 will be enacted on January 1st
2024 and if retail department stores
choose not to comply they will have to
dish out a civil penalty of $250 or $500
department stores that are subject to
the new laws will have to have a a total
of 500 and more employees be physically
located in California and sell Child
Care items or toys California Democratic
Congressman Evan low backed the bill to
the Associated Press saying we need to
stop stigmatizing what's acceptable for
certain genders and just let kids be
kids he said quote My Hope Is this bill
encourages more businesses across
California and the US to avoid
reinforcing harmful and outdated
stereotypes low said so the bill will uh
end the segregated aparti like
conditions and toy stores in the state
getting rid of gender labels and
allowing toys to express their true gend
fluid identities this is all meant to
reduce harmful
stereotypes now you may be wondering if
you're a sane person how exactly does
the average toy section in the average
store reinforce harmful
stereotypes in fact you may be wondering
what a harmful stereotype even is or how
a stereotype can be harmful because
literally all gender stereotypes and
race stereotypes and ethnic stereotypes
are grounded in truth that's how they
become
stereotypes which is why you have never
in your life heard a stereotype about a
group of people and said to yourself
what I've never seen anyone in that
group act that way that's totally
outlandish no stereotypes arise when we
notice that certain groups of people
tend to act certain ways generally
speaking it's not
harmful it's mostly just neutral
stereotypes are an observation made
about groups and yes you can observe
groups and the way they
behave just is what it
is fortunately California state
representative Evan low does go into
more detail about this issue trying to
explain how and why gendered toys are
dangerous he says quote part of it is to
make sure that if you're a young girl
that you can find a police car a firet
truck a periodic table because they have
those in the toy section or a dinosaur
and then similarly if you're a boy if
you're more artistic and want to play
with glitter why not why should you feel
the stigma of saying oh this should be
shamed and going to a different
location now first of all this is
perhaps neither here nor there but as a
parent I believe glitter should be
shamed for both boys and girls I mean
glitter is a plague that has been banned
from my house entirely for both genders
glitter manufacturers should be raided
by the FBI and forcibly shut down and
all of their employees thrown in federal
prison even just just just one ounce of
glitter will produce a mess in your
house that can never be cleaned up a
glitter spill is like it's like
Chernobyl I mean you'll be dealing with
the after effects three decades later so
the stuff is cursed and should be
legally banned but anyway aside from
that it appears that Evan low is
laboring under the impression that
without this law in place girls Were
Somehow physically prohibited from
entering the aisles where fire trucks
and dinosaurs are are sold or maybe he
thought that these items were hidden
down some deep labyrinthine Corridor
where only those with Y chromosomes were
allowed to enter but this was not the
case you know without the gender neutral
toy law girls were easily able to find
fire trucks and police cars if they
wanted them in fact girls could more
easily find fire trucks and police cars
because you knew where to look things
were organized in a way that made
sense and there was nobody stopping them
from buying
them you know there was no toy store in
California or anywhere else in America
where if a girl went to buy a fire truck
there'd be someone there standing and
pointing and laughing at them and saying
why are you buying that you're a
girl that literally has never happened
in the history of toy purchases ever so
this bill is at the very best totally
unnecessary which ironically is
something that the author of the bill
basically admitted back when the
legislation was first passed watch once
this revised bill goes into effect
children's sections at Large retailers
like Target are going to look quite
different maybe one of these one
assembly Bill 1085 to band stores from
displaying children's clothing and toys
in separate boys and girls sections the
bill was introduced by Bay Area
assemblyman Evan low in February
requiring stores with more than 500
employees like Target Marshalls or
Macy's to display children's clothing
and toys and one undivided area of its
sales floor I am a parent of a trans
child parents sparked the conversation I
still am in favor of combining things
and then people can choose I think it's
a wonderful idea to smoosh um girl boy
stuff together some ask why change it
just because it has a male and female
designation doesn't mean that you can't
walk to you know a a male toy and vice
versa let's just have a kids section
news8 reaches out to to Lowe's office as
he's aiming to reduce stigma and
bullying in fact he says remove it he
provides a statement quote children
should be able to express themselves
freely and focus on more important
things than stereotypical gender Norms
major retailers like Target and others
support this legislation and many of
these businesses already have gender
neutral kids sections the state is
actually playing catchup on this issue
toys are Toys let's make safe spaces for
all children and let kids be
kids so stores are already doing this
which is why we need a law requiring
that they do the thing they're already
doing that appears to be the argument
because it has to go one way or another
right either this is a law that will
impose on retailers the burdensome and
utterly pointless task of rearranging
their stores to make the toy sections
less organized and more difficult to
navigate for customers or it's a law
mandating something that's already
happened so either the law is cumbersome
and pointless or redundant and pointless
or I suppose cumbersome and redundant
and pointless it could be all those
things I think it's likely in that third
category the new stopbox Pro is the
leader in Rapid access firearm security
that does not use batteries or
Electronics if you're on the fence about
getting one then you can now get one for
free the stopbox pro is the latest
evolution in Secure handgun storage and
it's proudly made right here in the USA
build on The Trusted foundation of the
original stopbox the pro is larger more
robust and even more versatile but the
Real Genius of the stopbox pro lies in
its patented hand gesture code lock
security doesn't mean inconvenience
that's the principle behind the stopbox
pro it's Sleek portable and discreet
ensuring that your firearm is stowed
safely yet always Within Reach whether
you're at home or on the go you always
have the stopbox stopbox is offering a
buy one get one free deal on their new
stopbox Pro on top of that if you use
discount code Walsh should check out you
get an additional 10% off so head on
over to stopbox usa.com right now click
click the link below and ensure that
your Firearms are secure and accessible
when it matters most that's stopbox
usa.com for their incredible discount of
buy one get one with an additional 10%
off with code Walsh but there's no
scenario where the law is necessary or
good that's because among other reasons
um the gender binary is one of the
fundamental defining immutable realities
of human existence and with it comes the
obvious physical differences between
Sexes but also as we've alluded to the
differences in Tendencies and interests
and that's why we've come to associate
baby dolls with girls and and toy toy
trucks with
boys they don't gravitate to their
respective toys because we have made
this
Association we have made the association
because they gravitate that
way girls are natural nurturers and
caretakers boys are naturally builders
and and uh and Fighters that's why girls
like the baby dolls boys like the trucks
and the action figures if left to their
own devices almost all girls and boys
will go in those separate
directions as
like every parent in history has
noticed so the left doesn't want to free
boys to play with dolls or girls to play
with trucks they're already free to do
that if they want to instead they want
to
engineer boys with feminine interests
and girls with masculine interests
they're not actually trying to break
outside of the binary at all which is
not possible they're trying instead to
confuse the picture within the
binary and that's
because as we learn time and time
again you can't actually break outside
of the binary it's not possible which is
why it's always funny to to make note of
the fact that the left inevitably ends
up accidentally reinforcing the gender
binary in their efforts to Deon
constructed I mean after all if you walk
into a section of the store and and you
see fire trucks and baby dolls next to
each other and you say oh this must be a
gender neutral section well then you're
affirming the gender binary just by
saying that you're acknowledging where
those toys usually are and where they
belong and now you see that they're
together oh makes it gender
neutral and laws requiring such
arrangements are also affirming it this
is the terrible fact that the can't get
around no matter how hard it tries the
terrible fact which is not terrible at
all in my view is the gender binary
there are two Sexes and those two Sexes
have distinct features and functions and
they have certain Tendencies and
proclivities and there's literally
nothing you could do to escape that
fact and by the way the the stores that
have tried to as mentioned Target they
made a big deal in 2015 when they so oh
we're going gender
neutral well if you go into a Target now
which you shouldn't you'll find that
after all of that hype they still have
the store separated by boys and girls
they just don't call it boy and girl
sections but they still have a section
where you get the superheroes and you
have the action figures and you have the
trucks and the dinosaurs and all that
stuff is together and then you got the
other stuff that's got a lot of pink and
there's girl stuff and there's and
there's the baby dolls and and Barbies
and and they still have it group that
way because it turns out that that's
just like that's where that's how it
makes sense to group them
and most of the customers that are
interested in the trucks they're also
the ones that going to be interested in
the
dinosaurs this is what happens when you
try to make non-binary toy sections or
by the way non-binary people for that
matter you know a person who identifies
as non-binary will usually end up
dressing in some weird clashing
combination of male and female
clothing this person let's say a woman
for example will be very careful to
incorporate feminine and masculine
elements in the way that she dresses and
comports herself or at least that's what
she'll try to do and usually she'll
still end up looking like a woman just a
woman with a goofy sense of sty style
but even if she succeeds in appearing
like some kind of mismatched jumbled Mrs
Potato Head doll with male and female
elements mixed together still she has
not escaped the binary because still she
only has male and female elements to
work with there is no third or fourth
category you can be a woman who looks
like a woman or you could be a woman who
looks a little bit like a man or you
could be a woman who looks like some
sort of avanguard combination but no
matter what you are or where you are
you're still stuck in the binary those
are the only pieces you have to work
with those are the only categories that
exist and in fact the more you try to
escape the binary the more you make
yourself into a reminder of it if You'
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed